طلعنا من بلادنا ت هجاج من بيت حنون
تردونا من بيت حنون هدود هد هد بيوتنا
سكنا مدرسه الح الثانيه هنا قعدنا شهرين
ونص اج دمر المدرسه علينا اسر الاثنين
اسرع خذوهم وابن الثالثه ك مرمي جريح
والله في رجله اخوه في رجله هذا احنا
مهجين وحد مش لاق ح الطحين احنا نعجنها
اقسم لك بالله وضعنا صار زي الزفت الله
يفرج علينا يا رب علىكل متضايق وتحل على
خير وسلامه يا رب بنا والله بنا والله
العظيم ورانه يما و وروحوا دورهم روح على
دورنا وساعدونا والله العظيم ما عننا حبه
طحم بقول لك سلام عليكم كيف حالكم انتم
احنا في وضع سيء بدنا الامان وبدنا
استقرار في بيوتنا وبعدين احنا قاعدين
يعني تنقلنا 100 خمس مناقل من حفصه من هنا
من هنا كل هذا وه قاعدين في بيت محروق
والله صف محروق وعننا عزوز خبير 5 سنه
عمرها مش قدر حتى انكسرت رجلها وبدها
كروسي كمان ودور دمروه روحنا لقينا الدور
كله ممسحات مسح الوطن ايش بنعمل ايش ب
نسوي يا رب يا رب حل علينا يا رب اطلعنا
بس اطلعنا يا رب الحمد لله علمنا الله
الحمد لله احسن ادنا سردوا ولادنا تكتل
مات ودورنا انهدت علينا ش نسوي قاعدين في
الخيمه صف
خربان مش عنده ولا
واحد وجيت هنا على سب زيتون وكان معي اللي
هو ثلاث بنات
وولدين وجيت هنا وظليت عند ابو زيتون في
مدارس ابو زيتون وقاعد يحكوا عننا الجيش
يعني اطلعوا على على جبلي البلد وجيت انا
هان واللي بنتين وولد استشهدوا هان في
المدارسه يعني واحنا بنعاني في معانه
شديده
و مش عارف اي اقوللك انا يعني الوضع عندنا
سيء كثير من ناحيه الميه ومن ناحيه
الكهرباء ومن ناحيه الطحين وزي ما انتم
شايفين وضع زي الزفت ماساء
جدا لا اكل ولا شرب ولا
ادويه اللي بتصوب بموت ما فيش ادويه ولا
ميه حتى
نشرب